hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the most striking features of
Martin heidegger's interpretation of
Plato's famous allegory of the cave
found in republic book seven is his
talked about for dwelling places that
are being discussed in the allegory and
and he's focusing on the fact that we
not only have these four places but that
we have these very important transitions
taking place between them and there's
there's two things that I think really
ought to be said about this so Heidegger
particularly in his later works is going
to use this language of dwelling but I
think here we want to not worry about
his own particular use of that and think
about the fact that he's just revealed
to us that in Plato and really in
general one of the key features of
education is that it involves not just
giving us information not just teaching
us certain skills but as he's put it
accustoming ourselves to a certain way
of relating to being so that it can't be
rushed
it can't be pushed you can't lifehack it
you know into you know a speedier
resolution or anything along those lines
so dwelling really is an important idea
here and these are dwelling places for
the the person who is coming out of the
cave and going back into the cave so
that's one thing to keep in mind the
other thing that I think is really
interesting is the fact that these
aren't these dwelling places these
transitions are not exactly what we
might expect from Plato's own
explanation of the allegory that he
provides for instance in the third part
we don't see any sort of transition from
looking at you know reflections of
things to looking at the things
themselves so finally looking at that
which is illuminating all of them the in
this case the Sun which is supposed to
represent the form of the good
and so you might ask yourself well why
is Heidegger doing this a little bit
differently and I think that will become
clearer as we move through these
different things so he tells us the
unhidden and on in its unhidden estroux
--the ilithyia designated each point
what is present and manifest in the
region we're human beings happen to
dwell and then the allegory he says
recounts a story of passages from one
dwelling place to another it's divided
in a general way says into a series of
four different ones in specific
gradations of up and down so he says the
distinctions between the dwelling places
and stages are grounded in the different
kinds of Allie faced normative at each
level that is the different kinds of
truth that are dominant at each stage so
this is a particularly important issue
it's not merely that we're getting you
know closer to the truth in heidegger's
point of view it's rather that we're
dealing with different conceptions or
different attitudes towards truth at
each of these stages or in each of these
dwelling places so the transition is a
transition from one attitude or
conception or if you like comportment
towards truth into another so we begin
with the first one and this is the one
that is familiar to everybody all these
people are chained in the cave they see
the shadows on the wall in front of them
they cannot see the fire behind them or
the people you know working the
marionettes they're stuck looking
straight ahead and what is the truth for
them what is being on you know revealed
what is being made manifest it's the
shadows and that's all that they have so
Heidegger says these people are
engrossed in what they immediately
encounter the description of this
dwelling place you know ends with this
emphatic sentence in no way with those
who are chained like this ever consider
anything else to be the unhidden except
the shadows cast by the artifacts that's
the way in which he's translating
this is this platonic passage and so
that the cave can be a metaphor for the
the world that we live in which is the
way Plato is depicting it not only a
world that we live in as as you know you
might say human beings that see
everything visibly but the political and
the cultural world that we live in
until somebody begins to question we all
have the shackles on that's that's the
point of that so that's the first stage
that's the first dwelling place then he
tells us as we transition the stage to
the chains are removed and these people
can turn around
Heidegger lingers on this quite a bit
and this is a very interesting dimension
here Plato actually passes over this
fairly quickly he doesn't tell us that
you know these people are spending a lot
of time looking around trying to figure
out what's what inside of the cave but
Heidegger tells us that the truth here
or the the you know revealing or or as
we call it unhidden 'us is the
translation here is that of the visible
things but in the glow of the fire
Heidegger actually draws some other
important implications out here that I
think do fit the Platonic narrative
quite well but which Plato doesn't
discuss in in as much detail he says the
things themselves will offer their
visible form in a certain way in the
glow of the man-made fire the cave
they're no longer hidden by the shadows
they project so they're able to see for
example the marionettes or appt erratic
all the things that are casting the
shadow and they can also see the people
behind they can't see this that well but
they can see something there so there's
been a transition right and he says as
long as one encounters nothing but
shadows they hold one's gaze captive and
insinuate themselves in place of the
things themselves but when one's gaze is
freed from its captivity it becomes
possible for the person who's been free
to enter the
area of what is more unhidden or I'll a
theta le faith estará in the Greek right
what is more truthful what is more
revealing itself what is more on hidden
and there's two points that Heidegger
kind of stresses here that I think are
quite important one is that this is
still a man-made environment this is
still a thoroughly humanized environment
there's a cave we don't know how the
cave got there but the cave has been
illuminated by fire that people have
brought and the things that we're
casting shadows are things that people
have been using the other thing that's
important here is that there is a kind
of blinding and uncertainty that's going
on here he says that the glow of the
fire which their eyes are not accustomed
to blinds those who have been liberated
this blinding hinders them from seeing
the fire itself any apprehending how its
glow illuminates the things and lets
these appear for the first time so it
takes some being accustomed to dwelling
in that area before they can actually
realize that there's more to the story
than just what they were getting before
they already suspect that there's more
going on but they don't have it
distinctly they are not able to grasp it
until their eyes become accustomed to
the fire and so he says the word all a
face occurs at the end of description of
stage two now in the comparative degree
I lay tests that are other more on
hidden the more proper truth is to be
found in the shadows so even those he
says who've been freed from their chains
still assess wrongly in what they posit
is true because they lack the prior
condition for assessing that is freedom
and so you know this might explain to
some degree why Plato does not linger on
this dwelling place of the same cave but
now being able to turn around and
look at things and you might say this is
also the realm of those who were casting
the shadows
although Heidegger doesn't go into that
then we have an important transition to
what we normally take as being the most
important and determinative part of the
allegory itself the world in this case
the visible world seen as it truly is
which is an allegory for the world of
the Platonic forms the world of pure
ideas says real freedom is only attained
in stage three what happens in stage
three
they are led into the open their lead up
into the world and he says above ground
all things are manifest the looks that
show what things are no longer appear
merely in the man-made and confusing
glow of the fire within the cave there
is a better form of illumination and
this is permitting the things to shine
forth as what they truly are it's no
longer just a shadow of a tree or a
puppet of a tree or you know whatever we
want to conceive it is it's an actual
tree and of course you remember Plato
himself says well first they kind of
look at reflections of the the tree or
the animal or whatever it happens to be
then they look at the tree itself then
finally they look at the thing that's
illuminating it namely the Sun so he
says above-ground all these things can
be seen the open into which the freed
prisoner has now been placed does not
mean the unboundedness of some wide-open
space here's a very important point
he says the open sets boundaries two
things one thing is not another thing
the tree is not the bird in the tree is
not the soil that the tree is rooted in
is not the you know parasitical vine
crawling up the tree we have plenty of
grapevines here in the part of Wisconsin
where I live and they they sometimes do
that so he says the open sets boundaries
the thing and is the binding power
characteristic of the brightness
radiating from
Sonlight which is also seen the sunlight
is being seen indirectly reflecting off
of things but eventually we'll be seen
by the person looking at the Sun
hopefully not for too long
hey and and what is this an allegory of
for Plato of course this is the world of
the intelligible forms the the world
that the people down here don't even
suspect is the case but that which
provides the intelligibility to all the
shadows and even the copies of the
things that are casting the shadows that
have been relied upon and similarly the
fire is in a certain sense you know just
a dim reflection of the Sun so he says
this level of dwelling is defined in
terms of what is normatively and
properly unhidden at this level so what
is the truth the truth is the visible
things what is unhidden is the actual
things as they are in the fullest form
of illumination that we can conceive of
as they truly are so he says this winds
up being the what nests
of a thing the most unhidden he says
shows itself in the what nests of a
thing what it is that the thing actually
is not what it appears to be in the
light of the fire not what it is
as a shadow but what it is as itself so
he says without such a self showing of
the what nests any and all specific
things in fact absolutely everything
would remain hidden there would be no
truth if this stage were not possible
and remember Heidegger is talking about
this as a dwelling place this is a place
where one would have to accustom oneself
and he talks about this some more he
says within the cave to shift to engage
one's gaze from the shadows to the glow
of the fire and focus on the things
manifest and fire light was it was a
difficult task that proved unsuccessful
now being freed into the open that's
outside of the cave requires fully every
bit of endurance and effort in order to
grasp the truth as such one has to
linger with it this is not something
that is
given in a flash of insight that one
just then has a mystical experience this
is something that is hard won through
contemplation and indeed for Plato also
through dialectic
so he says liberation doesn't happen
from a simple free you know removal of
the chains and it doesn't consistent
unbridled license rather it begins as
the continuous effort of a custom Inge
one's gaze to be fixed on the firm limit
of things so Heidegger will go on and
say authentic liberation is the
steadiness of being oriented towards
that which appears in its visible form
and which is most unhidden in this
appearing this is what Paideia truly is
about education but it involves grasping
the truth of things now here is where
Heidegger brings up something that that
really you know all of this has been
quite good this is something that I
think really captures something
essential to the allegory that otherwise
would be missed why does the person
return into the cave so in Plato's
account of it the prisoner
understandably feels some sort of
obligation or sympathy with or towards
his fellow prisoners and he says I
better go back in there and help them
out and explain that you know what
they're seeing is just a bunch of puppet
shows in the light of a fire that this
is amazing stuff
I'd better go help them out Heidegger
construes it in a somewhat different way
he says the essence of Paideia right
consists in this pity I go gay hold a
state suitcase the the turning around
the you might say transformation of the
entirety of the saw the soul or he's
translated as the human essence so he
says insofar as it is a turning around
it constantly remains an overcoming of
its opposite fedosya the lack of
education
the having not been formed the state of
being in the cave because this entire
thing was about Paideia coming out of
the cave so in order to maintain Paideia
there has to be a return to the cave so
he talks about this the allegory
includes the descent of the freed person
into the cave back to those who are
still in Chains
how does this go we know it doesn't turn
out very well for them and Heidegger
talks about the return into the cave and
a battle waged within the cave between
the Liberator and the prisoners who
resist all liberation he says this makes
up the fourth stage of the allegory
where the story comes to a conclusion
now this is a very interesting idea
because of course Socrates is in in
Plato's terms the guy who's come out of
the cave and in his back in the cave and
that's why he's going to get killed by
his fellow citizens who aren't chained
there or perhaps you know some of the
people that are working the puppet shows
we could talk about many other people as
occupying similar roles there's
something about being educated that in
Plato's sense and in the sense that
Heidegger's talking about that
necessitates going back to you might say
the locus of non education the locus
where the opposite of Education is
taking place you might say that if we
want to use metaphors so long as
education remains solely within the
ivory tower refuge it's not truly
education and here Heidegger says that
truth or Alafaya unhidden 'us is
precisely the overcoming of Paideia of
the lack of education the opposite of
education the privation of education so
he says that the story comes to a
conclusion
he says admittedly the word ollie face
is no longer used here
but this stage also has to deal with the
unhidden that conditions the area of the
cave that the free person visits now
once again and then he will go into some
very interesting reflections on the
notion of hiddenness and unhidden s so
what we see here is also a parallel
between Paideia and op idea along with
ilithyia
and it's opposite which in this case is
not you know hope pseudos the lie but
rather they they forgetfulness being
covered something like that so we have
these four dwelling places and the
entire allegory is a sequence of
movement that takes us back into the
cave ultimately but in a transformed
fashion
you